was sehen sie wenn sie in diese augen
schauen
glück
trauer
hoffnung
anne franks blick meint alles ihr
tagebuch ist zeuge ist ein bericht all
dieser gefühle und zustände die erste
deutsche verfilmung über anne franks
leben zeigt wie sie zusammen mit ihrer
familie flüchtet ein amsterdamer
hinterhaus dient als zufluchtsort vor
den nationalsozialisten ihre welt
schrumpft auf ein paar quadratmeter
zusammen eine enge in der sie zwei jahre
lang leben wird
die machbaren dürfen nicht wissen dass
wir jemand legt bald sieht eine zweite
familie in dasselbe verstecke sieben
menschen dicht aufeinander
und mittendrin eine 15 jahre alt wieder
in der pubertät selbst wie bei einem
karussell dreht sich alles von den juden
zum essen vom essen zur politik
regisseurin jennifer ruhigem und
schauspielerin leilah fiasko erarbeiten
ihr ein personen stück zu anne frank
wie im kinofilm fokussiert auch sie im
konzert theater bern nicht auf die
historie sondern auf die figur auf das
mädchen anne frank als ich wollte
sozusagen hinter die ikone anne frank
blicken und ein mädchen zeigen in all
ihren widersprüchlichkeiten mit allen
ecken und kanten die lebendig und vital
und frech ist aber auch sehr verträumt
und so viel hoffnungen hat das wollte
ich unbedingt auf die bühne bringt
hier im hinterhaus findet mich jeder
übertrieben wenn ich versage lächerlich
wenn ich schweige ich wenn ich eine
antwort gebe gerissen wenn ich eine gute
idee habe v wenn ich müde bin den ganzen
tag höre ich nichts anderes als er sich
ein unanständiger fragt bin
wir wollten das heilige dass das
betroffene aus dem thema ziehen und und
eben dieses mädchen aus fleisch und blut
zeigen mit der man sich wirklich
identifizieren kann
was sehen sie wenn sie diese augen
schauen
abenteuer liebe oder angst
vertreibung und ausgrenzung prägen ihr
leben sie giert nach freiheit und
gerechtigkeit
es herrscht krieg und anne frank sehnt
sich nach der ersten liebe mal ist sie
nachdenklich
dann wieder beschwingt und leicht etwa
wenn sie witze über das leben im
hinterhaus erzählt zu verlieren kommt
nun ein verstecks kommission verfasst
der prospekt und neid fand vom
hinterhaus
während des ganzen jahres gelten
schöne ruhige weitere umgebung im herzen
von keine privaten nachbarn miete ist
gratis und jegliche verträgt eine frank
und ihre familie werden von der ss
entdeckt in den letzten monaten des
zweiten weltkriegs sie stirbt anfang
1945 im konzentrationslager bergen
belsen
die welt steht hier auf dem kopf die
anständigen menschen werden verhaftet in
konzentrationslager und einsamen
erzählung geschickt und der abschaum
regiert über arm und reich jung und alt
es ist ein plädoyer für die
menschlichkeit es ist so ein also für
den zusammenhalt und die hoffnung die
hier tatsächlich hat zuletzt stirbt und
mit solch einem plädoyer kann man
heutzutage auf jeden fall auch etwas
anfangen
anne frank eines von über sechs
millionen opfern
sie musste sterben für die perverse idee
einer reinen rasse ihr tagebuch eine
chronik des gesellschaftlichen
niedergangs
gleichzeitig nimmt ihr jugendlicher
blick dem zivilisationsbruch die schwere
es ist diese perspektive die ihre
geschichte zu unserer geschichte macht
wir schauen in ihr gesicht und sehen
auch und selbst